in an exclusive interview we're hearing
for the first time from the grandfather
of a toddler who died after falling from
a cruise-ship window
Salvatore Sam anello is charged with
negligent homicide in the death of 18
month old Chloe Wiegand in Puerto Rico
an emotional conversation he begins to
answer questions about his role in
Chloe's death including new details
about his health which may be critical
in court we also have new information
about surveillance video shown to CBS
News last week our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is
following the story David what have we
learned good morning to all of you that
video that was shown to us by attorney
Michael Winckelmann who represents
Chloe's family he does not represent mr.
anello in this criminal case that video
is somewhat different we reported
initially that it showed an L o and
Chloe appearing to walk up to the
railing which looks similar to this one
and that mr. anello looked down out of
the window for about a second that he
picked Chloe up and held her over the
railing for about five seconds turns out
it was longer the video shown to us was
not in real-time
the grandfather actually looks out the
window for about eight seconds that he
reaches down he picks Chloe up and he
holds her over the railing for nearly 25
seconds prosecutors believe that was
reckless attorney Winckelmann says the
video that he showed us was the same
format that he received from prosecutors
in a statement he told us any variation
in time likely has to do with software
issues most importantly whether it was 5
10 or 30 seconds does nothing to change
the fact that Sam reasonably believed
the window was closed yesterday my
producer and I flew to Indiana just sit
down with Sam for his first interview I
saw her fall I saw her fall
it's our fault and I was just in
disbelief I was like oh my god and then
I just remember screaming that I thought
there was glass and walked me through
what you remember alright so she's down
at the looking at the out the window and
the glass I bent down by her and and we
always like when you're whatever about a
hockey game is we would bang on the
glass and it was fun you know so when I
knelt down to be with her at that level
I couldn't reach the glass really the
one with my fingertips so I knew she
couldn't so that's when I decided I'd
pick her up so I you know was trying to
stand her on a railing and it happened
in seconds can you show me how you were
holding her like was it kind of a bear
hug or was it and uh yeah I was trying
to hold her like that ain't from what I
remember I had her and I was trying to
knock on the glass and at that point I'm
like well I'm gonna have to lean further
for her to be able to reach it right
because I thought it was further out
than I expected you had one arm around
her in the other arm you were trying to
knock on the glass yes they have one
point yeah okay and I think that's the
point where she slipped out of me I'm at
no point during that a whole incident
did I think that all she fell out it was
like it was unbelievable it's like it
disappeared it's like the glass
disappeared I don't know if there's a
feeling more helpless than watching her
fall know and realizing you can
just seems like it's so not real she's
such a beautiful girl perfect little
girl smile little girl
smart smart little girl then everybody
should have been able to know that
everybody should be able to know the
video that CBS News saw and I saw myself
appears to show you holding Chloe above
the railing and over the railing I have
to think a juror who watches that may
think that was reckless not knowing that
there wasn't a glass there if somehow I
thought that she was going beyond the
glass I wouldn't have done it I would
have been appalled I wouldn't mess
around with Chloe in a data kind of or
anybody with that dangerous kind of
never and ever if there was some kind of
warning sign there we wouldn't even be
near it we wouldn't even been near it
anello at that point asked to pause the
interview so he could take a simple
water
okay I have I have to tell you and I
don't know how much you have been
following the news but in posting the
story people that I've seen comment on
this don't think you should have been
charged whether you know they find me
guilty of whatever or not it's
inconsequential because of what has
already happened is so horrible some of
the people have been on the boat have
written to me and said David the windows
are tinted and so it is pretty easy to
recognize that it's open I am color
blind so that's been told me that's
something that you are colorblind
colorblind Eve I don't know I just never
saw it
I've been told that that's a reason that
it might have happened who did you blame
in this situation I the more more days
go by you know initially I couldn't I
couldn't help but blame myself but I
know that I know that if there was a
sign if there was a something that
indicated there was a chance for that
window it being opening that this
wouldn't happen so you blamed the cruise
line I do it's hard to you know yeah I
want I just want them to fix the boat
just fix it just fix the boat
what was your lowest point I don't know
if I've reached it yeah what's keeping
me going now is the process right now
and when it's over regardless of the
outcome
I think I'm gonna need some some help
mister anello is due back in court on
December 17th in Puerto Rico he faced
his three years in prison if convicted
you know the little girl's mother told
me last night that she actually asked
Puerto Rican prosecutors not to go
forward with the case and Chloe's mom is
actually a prosecutor so she understands
that decision of whether or not to
prosecute I should tell you the family
attorney actually showed us medical
records after the interview that appears
to support mr. Mandela's claim that he
is colorblind and clearly that is going
to be a part of their defense Chloe's
parents plan to file suit against Royal
Caribbean before the end of the year in
a statement the cruise line called it a
tragic accident but said they would have
no further comment out of respect for
the family and because there is a
lawsuit how does this case go forward
David look prosecutors are not going to
back down it's been made very clear to
us they believe mr. Anela was reckless
they believe the video is crucial and
they plan to pursue the trial where's of
that family
indeed watch thank you very much